Star Wars is back in a big way but a new
generation of fans and box office
records isn't enough to satisfy some
people that's why there's a petition to
bring back George Lucas to direct
episode 9 and it has over 20,000
signatures already but how does that
make Colin Trevorrow the current
director of episode 9 feel you may
recognize Trevor 0 as the director of
Jurassic world the second highest
grossing film of 2015 behind the force
awakens speaking to Entertainment
Tonight he addressed the petition to
have himself replaced it's funny I saw
that and it was on a day where i was at
Lucasfilm giving this big speech to
everyone about how we want to channel
the invention in just the raw creativity
and the boldness that George brought to
these films and not being afraid that
we're going to embarrass ourselves by
doing something that might be crazy but
it's the greatest story ever told I just
want to embrace that kind of invention
and creativity that he brought to it
Trevor Oh certainly doesn't seem fazed
by the internet petitioners who want to
see him replaced Star Wars Episode nine
is due for release sometime in 2019 in
the meantime there's plenty of Star Wars
news and movies to fill the gap and
we'll have all of them covered at
gamespot